Let's go next to the color from the three
one, three area code.
Who's calling today from three one three.
Hi David.
My name is Kevin.
I'm calling from Detroit, Michigan.
Hey Kevin, what's going on?
Hi, how are you doing?
I'm a really huge fan and I just had a quick
question.
Um, uh, I like to become more politically
informed.
Um, I find myself and I try to find out like
things on issues depending on a website that's
like kind of biased in certain ways and I
just trying to figure out a way how do you,
so, um, politically informed in a way you
do what you seem like you're strong.
Uh, um, you look at it from so many different
perspectives and not really indeed that, and
I want to be more like that.
So I was wondering how, how do you do that?
Well, the most important thing is when you
want to really understand an issue, you're
not going to understand it by reading liberal
and Conservative opinion pieces written today,
right?
Like if you really want to understand abortion,
it's like, okay, you can go and see what a
liberal blog says and what a conservative
blog says about the latest Arkansas proposal.
But to really understand it, you actually
want to be reading the history of the abortion
debate in the United States to kind of build
up the pyramid of, uh, the of, of knowledge
so to speak.
So the problem that I see for a lot of people
who end up very sort of uninformed or at least
shortsighted on political issues is that if
you imagine a pyramid, the base of the pyramid
is like knowing how to think.
It's critical thinking and it's basics of
philosophy.
Then you've got to understand how government
works.
So it's like basic civics.
We're building up this pyramid.
Then it's particular issues, the history of,
of abortion, for example, only the very top
of the pyramid.
It's sort of like the junk food in the old,
uh, a dietary pyramid that was floating around.
The latest news about x or y is like the junk
food.
It's the very thinnest part of the pyramid.
And if you skip to that, you're not really
going to know how to even think about a lot
of these issues or understand how they became
political issues to begin with.
So I think the important thing is separate
from the day to day news as much as possible
and read about the history of these issues,
read about critical thinking and sort of how
to think and epistemology.
That's the best advice I can give.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it that you know, what's
my, what's my job?
I'm actually in a Marine Corps and I'm also
a black man, so a lot of times I get,
oh no, whatever you, whatever you're saying
sounds super interesting, but you just cut
out.
You said you're a black man in the Marine
Corps and sometimes you get what you cut out
right there.
I get, I get pulled into like a lot of political
debates despite my best efforts to avoid it.
I see.
And you would like to just be more informed
in those debates it sounds like.
Right.
I generally lean towards the left but I just
don't want to fight off CNN or Fox was definitely
not Fox News, but I don't want to set off
to some like headline, you know,
your instinct is the right one and I would
really try to, you know, build up the lower,
the lower stages of that kind of a knowledge
knowledge pyramid.
Kevin, really appreciate the phone call.
Hope to hear from you again.
Definitely you pick your name.
Okay.
See you later.
Take care.
Um, okay, let's go.